how do you know a protagonist is a
character you want to write about like
how do you know you're really connected
to that protagonist hmm that's a very
very good question
I think for me it comes from a little
bit of the story and about what I want
to say at that time I don't tend to tend
to go with you know tropes of characters
I really go with like what's the
situation and what character can be
tested the most in that situation you
know the most recent thing that my
writing partner will and I have done is
a horror feature with a lot of like very
social you know very topical social
commentary and that just came out of you
know a specific very interesting idea of
horror but also the fact that right now
there's a lot of you know disparity in
terms of people's pay just in the world
you know the rich are getting richer and
the poor are getting poorer and that
middle class is disappearing and
everything and that's been very top of
mind for me so I wanted a protagonist
for this horror script that really like
embody that and somebody like this
blue-collar worker in Chicago that we
can all identify with and get behind
because I I think at least I do but I
think that we all feel like we are that
person right now you know like the
corporations you know are they're just
stepping down on us and politics is
stepping down on us and you know there's
there's a lot of unrest and an upheaval
I think and yeah it's just it's one of
those things that the situation sort of
can dictate that and and it's something
that I'm finding that having very
socially conscious statements is
something that I really want to put out
there because I think that I mean films
are a great medium
that you know you can reach a lot of
people with and if I can put messages in
there you know that will make people
think of something a different way you
know like thinking about the disparity
between black people and white people
and you know in a corporate environment
or you know with no touching it was
about you know the reach of misogyny you
know I really want topical you know
things that people can just really sink
their teeth into and make them think
that's that's my big goal with with my
current projects at least what were the
movies growing up that were like that
that made you think about sort of social
commentary like I like Norma Rae comes
to mind I know that's before my time
even but you know it's not just a
feminist story but it's also story about
a small town yeah people being scared to
lose their jobs yeah this is the only
place for them to work yeah and being
like just you know all of them are sick
and different things are happening but
what what different films growing up
sure I think for me what's interesting
is that it wasn't really like dramas or
things like that I found those messages
in like sci-fi and and popcorn films at
the time so the matrix was like the
first one that really opened my mind to
you know the thought of you know what if
none of this is real you know like just
the mind expanding aspect of like really
looking at the systems that we have and
and trying to figure out like how much
of this is real how much of it is not
and that continues on with V for
Vendetta which i think is you know an
amazing piece that again really gets you
thinking even though it's you know like
comic book and action and that's stuff
that I just love and I'm drawn to but
the ones that feed in that social
commentary are great and children of men
is another example of just you know a
sort of cautionary tale about the future
so those are the ones that I would say
really sort of did a great job of
it's popcorn movies but sneaking in some
very important social commentary have
been on a Raymond Chandler kick and so
I've been researching just different
panels and this USC panel talked about
his writings and he just said that so
much of noir was a commentary on really
the working class versus the wealthy
especially in LA in the 30s and all this
corruption and it just sort of just you
know paid off politicians versus sort of
a working man yeah and so it's just
interesting because you wouldn't totally
you see it as more of just a mystery but
that woven in is this commentaries yeah
and that's that's the real great Trojan
horse aspect of film it's like people
are there to be entertained but if you
can you know sort of trick them a little
bit and and give them a little dose of
social commentary that they'll go out
going like what was that actually about
her I'm thinking about that now her
opens our eyes like that's great that's
a wonderful trick
you